hello welcome back to our lobby GDC
sessions live from the game spots to do
mere blocks away from moscone center
where a game developers conference is
kicking off are you having fun there
adam saltsman yes you are are you having
fun there Jim Crawford basically uh I
had to split the Saltzman I wasn't I
wasn't leading you out Rebecca I was I
was putting I was just you're totally
living well gotta put your in a sandwich
you're in a crawford sandwich here frog
fraction sounds nice it's beautiful
thank you so much for coming in and
talking to us today and about all things
video games Jim who are you for the
pilot who don't know I'm Jim Crawford I
uh they're most likely to know me I made
a game called frog fractions if you
don't know what that is and it's that's
okay yeah most people in the world don't
that's the perfect way to play it is
they not know anything exactly you want
to that you want that to be the your
mental state when you go in to play it
it's like watch it's like when somebody
tells you i haven't seen like cabin in
the woods you're like oh I wish I was
you go watch cabin in the woods good
movie go play five versions you learn
all about frogs and fractions and
nothing else mm-hmm exactly than a no
other content in that game I'm delighted
to have you here because you did one of
my favorite GDC talks which we'll get to
in a little while cool that retaining
mystery in games right which i think is
something not a lot of people do and i
was very interesting talk i'm also great
very happy to have you guys in as well I
creators of well what games you shopping
around at the moment actually uh well
we're shopping shopping around overnight
no shopping it sweating and bleeding um
yeah we've been making game called
overland for about two years which is
sort of a survival strategy game with a
lot of roguelike elements procedurally
generated permadeath all that kind of
thing but with more of a focus on
scavenging and collecting and managing
resources and a little more than murder
there's well there's some murder still
every game ass that's not a video game
if you don't have murdered yeah there's
a checkbox I mean we got it we got to do
the thing um and we're also publishing
game called night in the woods
which is I is going to sound like a big
exaggeration but it's it's just the best
written video game that we've ever seen
and we're just super lucky to be
involved can you tell us about the
murder in night in the woods uh that
would know actually it's still under
wraps I that yeah we're focusing on the
platter if I even say like even saying
you guys fix the rocket jumps yet oh not
yet no no we're still tuning we've got a
spreadsheet with all the basic weapon
stats and everything and it's gonna be
fine yeah if you can make the railgun be
like I can change the color on it that
way yeah your window closed beta and we
have a really heavy crafting system for
all the weapons too so silencers what
else do you do on a thing handles can
you build your own levels using very
easy-to-use tool kit I know okay no no
it's really hard to be levels actually
it is its ongoing brutale yeah that's
what you guys been doing for a couple
years it sounds like you're also based
out of Austin the sort of crazy cool
like video game collected it seems to be
down there yeah we actually kind of
built the community over the last 12
years Adams part one of the board
members lagos rancheros you should be
run with a bunch of really cool people
and it's yeah there's a lot of Indies in
the space now and doing really really
cool things like across the spectrum of
like marketability and like super
experimental stuff so yeah it's a really
cool place to be how did that come about
was it just like austin is like a cool
place that was like shut to live at one
point it back in two thousand for really
cheap to live it was it seemed like um
like a trick like somebody was always
about to jump up and go ha no no no you
can't actually get this like beautiful
apartment right by downtown in the woods
for five hundred dollars a month Jesus
colleagues well it's technically 650 but
it was a two-bedroom two-bathroom
apartment we go like on a green belt
where did you come from we're from
Michigan's go ok that's the accent all
right it'll come out just wait for the
vowel okay yeah I mean he's from New
York maybe wasn't
yeah uh yeah we moved a move to Austin
so when when I went to school there was
no there weren't there wasn't really
game school digipen did exist there was
a sort of a weird program at MIT I could
not afford to go to either those schools
I and art center was totally out yeah
that was not going to happen and all
those things were kind of a stretch to
like everybody's trying to figure out
like what does it even mean like digipen
was almost like a Nintendo programmer
feeder school really the time was real
weird and so sort of like cobbled
together a game like education at a
normal university and that was kind of
weird and interesting and then had to
pick a place to move extra from Michigan
which is like auto industries yeah
especially in like the early two
thousands like I mean there's no tech
they're like even Google didn't show up
until after like I graduated there was
one game company there and um Brad we
are formally a double fine I used to
work there um and we knew him back when
we were in college and that's where he
worked on alter echo oh right yeah yeah
his name at a company uh-oh grab what
were they called those guys that made
descent yeah I'd never realized i
started with a V maybe I really narrows
it down he's been around all over the
place now he's back up and see I think
there was I think it was it volition was
it was it connected was that old
Volition's duty I don't member volition
of saints row fame I haven't think uh
yeah I can't be so who's that in Austin
there then cuz you presumably went down
when there wasn't many people yeah well
there are a ton of people there without
their all right they got their eye on
storm Austin oh cool I'm they had just
shipped deus ex origin systems was still
there which invisible war which oh sorry
yeah they were they were working on deus
ex two and thief three always is back in
1999's this is like 2030 boy okay what
times are yeah they haven't they hadn't
shipping that stuff yet they're still
there doing cool things and that trail
is there writing up Studios is there and
they still are um sony online
entertainment was actually still running
Star Wars they're all right kind of the
tail end of it and we're like yeah we
hired game job when Adam was I worked in
PR yeah I did media relations but that
like neither of us were nobody would
hire me because I was like an idiot with
no experience all right no idea what
they were doing that was the worst time
try to get into games
a little rough it was it was way easier
both like 10 years before and 10 years
after that yes yeah yeah I lent in like
it was weird growing up because we
didn't grow up with like good 8-bit
computers either mm-hmm so like like in
my teen years when I was supposed to be
like a weird hacker learning assembly
like it just never happened Yeah right
it was just like super weird gap so I'd
go to try again like well what's your
background making games like I mean so
many counter-strike levels it's so many
yeah scouts knives that was me yeah yeah
yeah so in this one this one is like a
giant it's like being in a giant kitchen
you are level lord yes i see hows
realize my real kitchen yeah yeah yeah
but couldn't get you couldn't get a job
or anything so kind of went got a normal
software job that was actually pretty
cool and eventually figured out I would
have I would have been terrible at a
triple a studio right and I would have
hated all of it but like only found that
out over the course of like years why um
a giant control freak I have a huge ego
I've really really strong opinions about
things even when I'm wrong like a whole
bunch of reasons I like doing things
outside of work sometimes right um
that's a big problem that was back in my
2005-2006 yeah it was pretty that's like
right around EA wife oye smells like a
thing so is it you know I'm all right in
saying that like your decision to jump
into indie development it's as much like
a lifestyle choice there's anything else
look bit I think it was more like like
Adam Adam had exposure to one particular
thing and it was like oh my gosh
somebody like a one person can make a
game anything kind of a big moments like
we were doing a little bit of freelance
work for triple-a companies here and
they're doing like little freelance for
advertising companies and then it was
just a I don't wanna like put on a
pedestal necessarily but there was a
really good like right time right thing
at the right time thing when i played
cave story for the first time alright
yeah and it was like whoa one dude you
made this whole thing and it's like
aesthetically consistent it sound like
an art game but there's like they're the
art and the music fit together really
well and
has this like really consistent mood the
modern version of this is like axiom
verge yeah like I'm very sure some kids
gonna play axiom verge and find out how
it was built yes go what while he was
working in a triple a studio it seems as
well for me yeah yeah for a big chunk of
it yeah so um yeah so that was that was
like oh you could do this like this is
like global like there's a you know it's
not easy it took him like five years or
something but like you could do this
what was your first game there um it was
let's see I post that there was a flash
quote-unquote game called nano hmm it
was a space shooter with one enemy type
one ship type it was 70 pixels wide but
just blown up really big because I
didn't have to work very hard on the art
and there was one kind of enemy wave
pattern and that was it mmm and then
like a little like NES soundtrack thing
it was algae you're a designer who likes
simplicity though minimalist yeah
minimalist I and this this was just I
what just wasn't even a game like you
could just play forever there was no
like sounds like space invaders which it
was a huge hit yeah right that's how you
do it yeah India you pick you pick it in
blaszczyk right just play your own twist
even on that like it was an unfinished
thing and I was like I don't want to
make all these other space ships like
this game just feels like a whole lot of
work but I wanted to put in a thing
where when you blew up the ships they
would drop little power-ups and that's
how you got your score and when they go
drop the power-ups the power-ups would
drift up toward the top of the screen
which is where the enemies come from so
if you wanted to kind of collect the
things while you were shooting the guys
you kind of had to get up close and like
there was already like a little risk
reward thank you and I think that was
like oh oh this is like a math thing
that you can do in a game and this is
like weird and it's real time and it's
like this is really hard to do in
anything else too like if this is a
feeling that you want and like a UH it
does what how you want people to relate
to the thing that you maybe you can kind
of only do that in games is one of those
things anyway so what if I said come
kind of all come around that was like
about trees yeah about two years after
games down yes that's where I started to
like get visibility on you yes was that
was that the big sort of
absolutely before that it was a gravity
hook the flash version of it and then i
fathom which is very much sort of like a
experimental art game which people
either hate it or love but has the most
beautiful soundtrack everyone always is
like Oh Danny like it's the the Canabalt
music like that's that's it uh listen to
fathom like fathom like it feels like
you're gonna weep Bosley it's like man i
fathom was like a little art game and it
kind of got it made some people really
really angry to head us it was it was a
bullfrog fractions no spoiler alerts but
um the ID and fathom is notable from is
I worked really really hard on making
like a whole level of like a mega man
cave story game okay so your little
robot guy with a gun you can run around
it's got really really good physics like
you shoot monsters shoot these little
guys that are hopping around they blow
up and pieces fly everywhere he's got
cool sound effects and it's got this
like Danny be before anybody even knew
who he was just like really intense
driving like our pezzi ated like
emergency uh-oh thing and then you get
to the boss chamber the doors slammed
down this giant like mantis head starts
coming out of the top and it switches to
Danny be boss music like full-on the
backgrounds flashing red and you
inevitably die and then you fall into
the water and it's this like super soft
sad thing and your gun doesn't work
anymore just shoots bubbles and you go
like swimming around making cleansing
fish oh really we can try thinking real
bad your your soul is buried down there
somewhere and you find it and you plant
it and it grows this black oh wow okay I
so black like an infected tree and it
opens this gate at the bottom and then
all you see is your self swimming up
toward the light and then and then all
you see is yourself sinking while the
credits roll I i had never liked there
was the coolest megaman game that I
played in a long time and then it got
all stupid and for you Marty's sounds
and rhythms this is like I have a
message for everybody I've talked to
before this podcast which is why didn't
you tell me about fathom
and now it's been ruined yeah it's still
good to experience I think what I just
did and what what is it about making
those types of games than what like cuz
presumably I know it's the cabin seemed
relatively cheap to live in Austin at
that time it was getting more expensive
presumably I had a real job attic really
do whatever he wanted like I'm like we
had on track it wasn't really yeah when
Adam went solo like on the indie thing
and like he's doing contract art and
stuff like I totally had a real job at a
software company we're like with health
insurance yeah this is something worth
diving in on like indie development
almost always means you have a day job
or savings or supportive spouse rights
more parents yeah so what about yourself
then because like not well I've got I
had a day job and then I had the
Kickstarter right yeah that's what I'm
living on right now I'm immediately we
actually did a survey we did like an
informal Twitter survey and went and
just got real like hey weird how do you
guys pay your bills and probably I would
say it looked like about twenty to
thirty percent of normal indie devs pay
their bills with sales from their
previous games right or twenty to thirty
percent of their bills are paid by that
but then everything else spouse second
full time job savings accounts work for
hire like all these other arrived I mean
and to get into that twenty percent you
need to have at least released one game
so right yeah that's somehow ram
chocolate and is somehow like action
making anything yeah right yeah that you
didn't already owe to someone else right
one thirty percent sounds really high to
me actually yeah I think there's there's
probably like some outliers and some
like look it's a lot of election buyers
yeah it's also only paying part of it
like we weren't we weren't very do you
mean like yes it's thirty percent of any
doves are not paying their bills through
revenue share aren't using their revenue
share to pay twenty percent of their
bills oh I see total Oh like that's very
different bills yeah it's so pretty
small so when did you stop supporting as
us oh so and yeah I had a really weird
experience I like the job that I was out
I started out was like a glorified
secretary at the software my job and
then I convinced them to let me do tech
writing even though i have no
ground and engineering or anything I'm
just really good at writing and I can
really get breaking things and like
describing how things work to people and
then from that after I learned all the
software suite for the software company
I convinced the CEO to create a position
and another position to be a product
manager but is actually more of a
project manager so I was like this weird
liaison between like our customer base
and the development team so I was
creating features and stuff and then
designing these with like the
development team but I was also working
directly for the CEO which was sort of a
really weird thing for me at this time
and I got super frustrated so I was an
idiot right he was like a huge idiot do
you want to join named him no it was is
really a hard place like it's hard to
work for someone you don't a hundred
percent respect yes yeah and everybody
else in the office was like wow like
these like someone of one of the guys is
still like one of my professional
mentors and I i was super frustrated i
came home from like a trade show like
fetal position crying to like the juno
soundtrack where's my hamburger so under
this fluffy down comforter with like
headphones I'm frying listening to moldy
peaches it was like whoa we gotta change
whatever's gonna know so at that point
Adam had actually gotten this fair to
fairly lucrative advertising contract
that had sort of bought us several
months cool um and then Wordle came out
right and we're all started like it just
extended the time that it took for me to
get a job so like he had already bought
me like three months and then weirdo
bought me more months and then the
recession happened right so there were
no jobs anyways but it we had bought so
many months that I never actually had to
go back and the whole thing was
intensely weird too i boiled down to we
accidentally worked on a boggle clone
for Iowa we didn't even know it was
boggle Klein never played boggle you've
never played boggle no I have no
childhood you have no I invented boggle
yeah how far was his feet apart for the
person who I only found this out I
didn't know a boggle awesome okay I
[ __ ] did it
not believing like dog under your nose
bacalao infant monopoly nowadays roof
should be a shame they do that it's
called like it's called the earth it
works pretty good um it was a Q&A no no
no this wasn't worse like I didn't know
I had I I thought that I worked on this
cool original thing I know like four
months yeah I had no ideas a boggle
clone cuz I I didn't do the gameplay
like crime someone else had done a game
play prototype and the art was a mass I
was like I'm gonna brand this we're
gonna like shine this up and I've got
graphic design background do this and
did it and it or like instantly became a
top 10 iOS hit right I'm just like thank
how much as wow we're professional gonna
make very different in 2008 yes yes it's
not no no not exactly clash of clans
tier yeah recess at this point and I so
were audited video game industry event
and I'm on a train and having this
conversation with I don't want to name
him so I feel slightly weird about it
but he's a really brilliant game
designer that especially at the time I
looked up to a lot and still do I just
think he's someone who does really
interesting work and he sits down and
goes so what does it feel like to have
made a crapload of money on a boggle
clone whoa did you know if boggle was
then no I was like why was like what are
you talking about and he's and he's like
here let me show you like I'm like like
a video you know here's what boggle
works and I was like oh okay so what's
ads at this deja that's cool it's been
out promoting our months i made like not
again not clash of clans money but we've
paid our bills we have a couple years to
mess around make prototypes now and only
then found out that it was like i don't
know i don't wanna say it wasn't like
totally illegitimate I felt it still
feel intensely weird okay clearly
because you haven't done it again I know
right I guess that's because that what
happens then is like you know if you
were if you were powered by money it
would be like oh [ __ ] great i found the
solution i'll just do that again we'll
do a scrabble next yeah police I mean
Johnson offered to do yeah contacted to
do Scrabble yeah so like you know it's
really good in kerplunk well we're gonna
play
so your partner presumably did know
about this uh yeah I found out later
yeah they totally did I exactly like
that was the project itself was just to
clone bottle yeah um it was weird what
you did a great job yeah yeah and your
people love that still a really top 10
boggle clans got a piece I gotta write
it down yet ah Jim let's talk about you
for a little second the hot second yeah
so what were you working on that you
were work that you were doing frog
fractions in your like your spare time
well I was I was uh I was not in the
industry I it's been a hobby for me for
20 years on and off but I was doing
website back ends oh really yeah and I
had been working on frog fractions for
about a year when I was laid off from
that job Wow and that was a few months
before I GF 2012 I was like I'm gonna
set this I'm use this as a deadline to
finish frog fractions and then I'm going
to get another web design not a web
design web programming job um frog
fractions blew up and Here I am like I
took that as an opportunity like I had
given up on uh on like I I had known for
a long time I wasn't cut out for like
triple a development for the cardio work
yeah yeah but I decided this is my
opportunity to maybe I can make a go at
doing the stuff on my own terms it's not
the first game you'd made that was the
first game that I made that anybody care
about Ryan were you surprised the people
cared about it because a very yeah no I
when I released that game i was i was
making it for my friends mmm i'd
expected like 30 people to play it um
but i had met Brandon Sheffield at Asha
game game dev show-and-tell six months
earlier and he had liked it any tweeted
about it and that was that like it
wasn't even officially released at that
time oh really it's just I was just on a
web baby was just on my website yeah
that it like almost the perfect way for
people to find us like yes when I
stumbled across that had felt that's not
so intentional like in this like
brilliance but why did this part like
getting into cuz i really think that
people should go buy it if they like
pause this and just go give yourself an
hour and come back yeah we're getting
into spoiler carry its it's a sort of
skirt around us like it seemed like the
reason why it was so wonderful was
because like oh there's this rabbit hole
exists and like a [ __ ] table unlike a
this most basic ass like website you
know it just keeps going and going along
I was huh a lot of that was deliberate
but a lot was also just really lucky
yeah yeah feel like people felt like a
sense of like um not ownership exactly
but those like a sense of discovery
because you're like look what I get out
no yo grand yeah yeah exactly you won't
believe this math name phibian game that
I've just discovered him yeah it's like
you it was almost yeah shareable thing I
mean like that's what we talked about
like trying to get like people to
purchase something or look at a website
like games but like shareability is like
the most important thing you made
something that yeah people were like
proud to like tell somebody strong viral
content yes yes yeah so how do you
follow that up again uh I can't tell you
yes well shoot some forum threads I've
seen some forms i followed up with the
kickstarter yeah that would that's
that's the true follow up to frog
fraction the kickstarter for frog
fractions to like that really was like
when i was working out how I was gonna
do the Kickstarter that was what I had
in mind was that this is actually the
sequel the Kickstarter itself yes yes
and then what people are funding is frog
fractions 3 and the question of how to
follow up the Kickstarter that's what I
can't tell you okay yeah it's so you've
done the caves on something which like
in win in some ways it's kind of like
like a dangerous proposition because
you're basically telling people people
are still playing the Kickstarter people
are still playing except as far as i
know i found the forum threads and the
kickstarter is not done yet really yeah
i know there's some some some game
elements of that that kicked off there
that have then moved on you know other
places okay yeah but you basically were
like taking people's money and then
saying oh yeah i'm gonna make something
the pro you're not going to know what it
writes the premise of the kickstarter is
you know you just give me some money and
maybe someday you'll find a cool game
somewhere yeah you know i don't i'm not
going to tell you what it is or
it is it's not gonna have my name on it
because if if any of those things were
true it wouldn't be a surprise yeah and
the point is the surprise how do you
okay he said I would you get away with
that but that's it's like I think I oh
nice just like cattle ya know that that
I shouldn't have gotten away with it
stands like straight-up know that I
should not have been able to do that but
I was like is this like a chance for
kickstarter backers like is like it
feels like in some ways the Kickstarter
was like for them to troll you oh yeah
yeah it was like hey guys back this and
then like stick me in this place where I
have to invent all this yeah yeah yeah
well I'm gonna be getting is this frog
fractions two questions for the rest of
my life even after people know exactly
what you're talking about this before
how like if there's an amphibian in a
game now yeah it's pretty mysterious
like you have you have increased the
overall value of video amphibians
impossible Jax is gonna smile because
you I'm proud I'm proud of what I did we
totally get it like we have a video game
that's coming out with an amphibian and
there is suspicion is it frog fractions
I don't think so you're on the same room
we are not at liberty to say yeah there
is its conspiracy now that what it is
how does that has it hasn't been an
enjoyable view since most are happen my
life's great yeah yeah I don't know well
I have a little bit of money I look so I
mean you're stretching the money pretty
I am I I pay ridiculously low rent for
the Bay Area um you don't yeah you live
in all in perspective in fruitvale
you're right yeah so you're not it's not
it's not like you're sitting on row
that's right somewhere in the mission
and I don't have health insurance but
but um okay but my life is great feel
free to buy health insurance i think
you're probably but maybe maybe maybe um
a single-payer system is frog fractions
three there you go provide vote for that
um yeah I make weird troll games for a
living my day job it's amazing you and I
did you would you be happy doing this
for us your life alright cuz there's
this thing about indie games are like
before I sort of knew the Spade like I'm
won't even do
it's like covering is like four years
before I'm like oh it's like a launchpad
rights like I get it's like the iceberg
rafters I nurse any do your own like
freelance stuff until you get like a
really well paying gig somewhere that's
like great like none of you people are
any of the people are like the party
last night or like wherever talk to ever
sound like they ever wanna get involved
in triple-a department oh yeah I know
mcpherson know yet not it's not a goal
and what we're all so darn picky oh yeah
betaine like just being like massively
picky and probably really clean I'm not
that hard to work with but Adams pretty
darn hard to work with I mean like not
things fine as long as they do exactly
what I want oh my god him can make the
decisions like there's no like anger and
fury really right so like that's our
struggle yeah that's like a trait like
the Indies have a passion to make their
own thing and they need to do it at
their own pace I that's like a big deal
and that's like a deep like seated
character treat yeah so like the idea of
making someone else's thing is like so
aberrant yeah that link even going
freelance was motivated by this like
intense sense of almost divorced the
idea is like in the long term that this
will pay off but in the short term it
was a concerns that didn't include money
at all which was just said I wanted to
bells gonna work on something for three
months six months nine months right when
I was done I wanted it to be really
really good you know occasionally you
would find yourself working for someone
who had come in and would force you to
make it bad yeah and it was just like um
I just uh this is probably a super
privileged position to be in but I
couldn't handle it which is like no no
no no no I spent a whole bunch of time
on it that I can't get back like I can
get more money later and I can lose it
like money is like very very fluid but
there's this like time resource yeah and
it's just disappearing and if I'm not
getting to do something cool with it
that turns out good that's just brutal
and like most people's jobs have things
that they don't like to do but most of
those things don't historically most of
my jobs in that but those don't take
three quarters of a year or two years or
five years which is the reality of games
or being really in charge of something
and then having someone come in at the
end and make it worse and that's like a
really hard thing if you're like you
know a creative person and you have
ownership over something and having
someone come in from the outside
no no this client wants this and it's
like you're leveraging your expertise
your experience you're saying like list
I've been doing this for a while I've
examined all the options and they say
well I don't like it hmm well I mean if
you fail your own terms at least that's
a learning experience where's you feelin
tonight slightly right you yeah and you
can't it doesn't like wasted my time
well it doesn't reach it forward yeah it
doesn't roll forward into a future thing
if you can do one really good thing then
you can do a Kickstarter about it right
so there's that but um can I ask you a
question is that ok to Dover yeah I'm
curious what prior life experiences
equipped you for making troll games for
living ah frog fractions is almost I
think there are you the guy on April
first he like was [ __ ] with all his
buddies no no no but that's mostly
because i'm accustomed to april first
jokes being like people coming up and
saying hey my mom just died you know i'm
sorry it's april fools wow its top shelf
april fools that's real Joker um I I I
do tend to troll people but always in a
very like good-hearted way I try not to
like make anybody the butt of the joke
that's really important to me mmm yeah I
might so my superpower when it comes to
making comedy games is that I will laugh
at the same joke over and over and over
and over again alright um which I this
is my theory for why comedy games are
rarely actually funny like you you need
to be able to uh just this is you know
when you're testing a game you're doing
tiny tweaks and tuning and you're seeing
the same thing a thousand times and I
was able to sit there and say like okay
how long should the bugs wait before
flooding the screen during the dream
sequence you know is half a second
funnier than a seventh of a second you
know you know yeah um and I was able to
trust my judgment as to whether Oh as to
which was funnier because it was funny
to me every time yeah
the punchline is like so difficult to
like I mean comedians don't even know
themselves anymore they test it on
crowds right see how they laughs yeah
exactly i don't even do that with a game
well like prototyping is rehearsing then
almost like Oh kinda just to make it
work and get all the kinks out like
you've automatically told yourself the
same joke like 300 times or something so
if it's still good by the end of that it
must be pretty good right I I my own
preferences as as you've been talking
about that's my guiding light that's all
I know like I can't I don't think I
could make a game for a hypothetical
audience right like I'm just doing
things that every decision every
creative decision I make is based on
what kind of game would what would I
prefer as a player at this point you
know what what am I what I enjoy most
and sometimes it's a long-term thing
sometimes um there's a little bit of
deliberate frustration in there mmm that
that I put in there just to pay off
later but it's uh it's always based on
what would I like and that's that the
kind of limits me to people who who have
the same taste as me in terms of my
audience but when it must really land
with those people yeah well and I'm just
lucky then that my particular taste
meets it was frog fractions had a
million and a half players Jesus
something like that was a free game so
yeah didn't actually make me any money
but um and then she backed up the server
costs though oh god I a soundtrack sales
almost covered server cups Christ
someday ask us about cannibal all right
good ah you did really music in your
free web games is my lesson really yeah
yeah yeah I was so happy that I
converted all the music from stereo to
mono say to be nice have your money
right yeah okay one side yeah you'd a
really good GDC to a couple years ago I
almost like stumbled into about like
retaining mystery yeah your games which
obviously you know like my job is to
ruin mystery for people right like where
I ensure Poland sure preview games and
well hopefully hopefully elicitors know
what they're getting into yeah but there
was something like really it was
fascinating to hear somebody talk about
what's something should almost be south
I've evident which is that like
obviously the more you know about a game
before comes out then the last
interesting it's like I don't know it's
it's yeah it's landings are like that's
the cycle that I that's the bubble that
I now live in that I probably didn't
even live in before I worked in the
price because you can kind of like jump
in and learn what you want but like
that's what advertising and publishers
in media that's what they're doing is is
trying to let people know as much about
a game as possible to delay point now
where we know basically everything a
better game before comes out exactly
like enjoyment is often based on our
expectation against the reality as
opposed to just the quality of the game
itself isn't it kind of impossible
though for like big triple-a games to
not tell people they just have to if
you're gonna make you kind of have to
make mystery a feature of the game and
you have to build it into the design and
and even the marketing strategy it's
it's very hard but if it is as it is in
in frog fractions if that is a
fundamental feature of the game it's
just something you have to live with you
have to say like well eighty percent of
people are probably not going to see the
good part yeah and that's not something
that triple a is usually willing to
accept and then you guys live without
reality as again trying to find like
trying to get your audience share before
the game comes out trying to like shout
louder than everyone else in a space
that you know like today even like worse
than ten years ago it is so much more
stuff hopping in Indies like any
comments not you know we like it's it's
really weird it's a it's a really weird
line to walk because like right now like
the only thing we care about when we're
marketing something like Overland is
that people have any idea what it is at
all right like we just want like like a
like marketing goal one is but basically
if they see the word overland yeah
they'll go oh it's like a strategy thing
like oh that's all we need to do is just
get that and it's really hard and takes
a really long time and if we don't do it
I will be getting a job next year right
I'll be getting a new job so like
there's we have to do that and um but in
a lot of it could to contrast this with
something like night in the woods which
we're also putting out like
we could legitimately spoil night in the
woods if we put out too much information
like we're gonna have this like you know
beautiful hundred thousand word epic
thing that's like no one's ever created
anything like this before and like even
people really close to the project like
out outside of like me and Adam and the
team people don't know anything except
what they've seen in like that demo that
we've been showing for two years non
purpose we have been kept keeping it
locked people like does this game still
exist we don't see you talk about it
much it's like because we will spoil it
yeah yeah because this story is it be
like someone coming up and being like
you want to know how harry potter and
let me tell you all about it it's like
like that's total BS so like creating
miss Greeks dad the whole time we're
like creating a mystery like an
anticipation like why would they keep
something locked down yeah i kin that's
part of the marketing stores it's kind
of weird for night in the woods in a lot
of ways to because it's not just a plot
thing like there's not i don't even know
if there's like even a single sentence
we could say that would spoil things but
if we were trying to communicate what
does it feel like toward the end of the
game yeah that's actually gonna be
almost like a tonal spoiler or something
like it's gonna take you to a place
nipple if you can see it coming to the
players far away or you have to see it
coming if the game doesn't look hair you
for it you know like the game I mean
this isn't for all games but I think for
night in the wood that's really
important that people kind of go in and
start experience it with a relatively
clean slate because and then the game
everything is in there to sort of take
you from step to step toward this place
and not as a not as a gameplay concern
but really as like a tonal thing as a
thematic thing as subtext as like and
there's like if we try to do that in a
in a trailer or something it's just not
gonna work so you don't read you don't
read chapter 27 of 45 like you don't do
that you don't open up the book in the
middle so yeah it's really really
important to be like like we're going to
take you from page one all the way
through the end if they find a thing you
have to find this thing that'll bring
people to the starting point yeah and
like a lot of our marketing approach now
the thing that we're the most
comfortable with is like how can we get
people
knowing nothing about the game to
getting them into this first little bit
of it yeah and find all the things try
to make the first part so interesting in
and of itself that it's enough to market
that part because you can't even
Telegraph that there is mystery you
can't even like tip your hat to it
because if you're like you have to be so
careful there because looking for yeah
yeah I mean it's like that spoiler alert
there are spoilers and everything yeah
it's I remember like spec ops the line
which was the third person like it's a
oh it's another shooter it's set in
Dubai super important that you go into
that thinking it's it's exactly it
literally had to marketers like every
other shooter yeah even though I really
wasn't what that project has over frog
fractions is that that's a decent
shooter like if you buy that box in the
in the store you're actually gonna get
the game you paid for anyway right yeah
yeah yeah I guess yeah I could yeah so
they're almost like doing both they're
like right yes appeasing their audience
work yeah that's like which is almost my
favorite thing you can do there's this
old there's this movie from maybe the
late 70s or early 80s called the
stuntman stars Peter O'Toole and other
folks and it's totally that like the the
the premise is about a Vietnam vet who
gets a job as a movie stuntman okay and
Peter O'Toole's this megalomaniacal
director who's putting together this
action movie but he's trying to make a
really certain kind of action movie
where there's a bunch of wacky stunts
and violence and all of that stuff but
underneath there's like a weird or
deeper message and the stuntman the
movie itself features all of these wacky
stunts and ends up becoming in structure
exactly what the megalomaniacal director
is making for the same reasons to carry
like another embedded message underneath
and so you can totally watch it as a
popcorn yeah key romance comedy that
maybe is a little weird because there's
a movie with in a movie but you can
totally absorb it on a surface layer or
you can start kind of like digging down
and rewatch a Shakespeare okay what
they're very cool and um I love that
like as as a way of connecting with
people it just seems like if you go if
you're going to go all the way to the
deep end and the deep end only
then you don't maybe you don't get to
say as many interesting things to as
many people right and that's even harder
than in video games where you don't have
that control you do over like movies
which is beautifully linear like I love
being a video I told the control
somebody looks away from the screen I
guess I can't control that but in your
games you're trying to get people to
figure things out for themselves that's
like another layer deeper when we do a
lot of weird things like we did it with
canabalt which we didn't provide any
story or background likewise this dude
jumping out the window like and there's
like stuff happen there's no story just
like a dude or a girl now because you
can play as either character like
jumping across rooftops it's the same
thing we're doing with Overland which is
like you don't know what happened like
there's no there's no background that
you're aware of like there's just your
you're on a road trip you're going west
and there are things coming out of the
ground and why and all you know about
like the people in this world are like
the two tiny sentences were giving you
which is something about their past and
something about their present and they
it's it's it makes the player especially
there are several people sitting around
sort of one person's playing while
everyone's sort of arguing like you're
playing pandemic or something yeah they
they get attached these people because
they have these weird stories and now
imagined like an entire backstory for
them and how they might be interacting
with each other it's really really
fascinating to sort of like strip out
like the the candy that you're giving
the player I guess like strip it out
like let's let's like use something a
little bit deeper and like after a play
session are you gonna go out and like so
I was on this like I was playing
Overland today and like I had like
Roberta and Frank and you know Zoe and
we were like in this car and we're
ending these monsters and like you know
Zoe was like prom queen and like you
know she's like looking for sister you
can create this and we had this dog like
you can create these like weirdos
stories it's like super fascinating to
see players do this yeah it's like the
way the dude people do it in like games
like XCOM it's more yeah exactly build
this story right to me it feels really
generous i really like the feeling of
building a thing and you let players
have some of the fun that you get to
have as a game designer like I always
feel like I just uh it's not I don't
know I don't know how bad of a feeling
it is but there's like a distinct sense
when you're playing a game you feel like
the designer
took like all the fun right like if
they're doing an RPG like they came up
with all the cool names for everything
already and they wrote all the cool
backstories already and they kind of
like used up all of that stuff and like
I kind of miss it is one raised I'm just
head over heels in love with Zack tronox
and the kinds of games they make like
infinite actory for example because so
much of infinite factory is infinite
actors super dangerous if you're a game
designer stay way away from it yes sadly
like you're a knob only way more fun I
totally had to ban him like he we went a
whole week and I'm like what mostly I
was sleeping like three hours doing
you're like we have two kids okay like I
wasn't shipping code like Adam legally
barricading himself into the studio for
like 40 plus hours staying up all night
playing a video game I'm like what the
hell are you doing k factorial I know
yeah I Torrio's well yeah I think Big
Pharma a kind of like is functioning
along the same lines like I love these
games that like like they let you into
sort of the game designer circle a
little bit obviously minecraft and other
games do this to its expressive but it's
also this particular kind of sort of
problem solving and lateral thinking and
then like filling in gaps and trying to
figure out what's in there and why
that's interesting and and you're saying
narrative Lee as well that exists where
some people like enjoy yeah I think so I
think so and it puts people I like I
think if you do it right to it does a
weirder as a weird like second order
effect of making them at least while
they're in your game kind of be more
inquisitive I think you can deliberately
the more if you're careful about it and
you leave these gaps for people to fill
in they will somehow like switch modes
of playing or something I think happens
when you're using really unexpected to
like when they get when they get a big
surprise when you when you make the
player fill in the gaps even something
like just to go because I only ever talk
about frog fractions understandably an
example from that um you have to hold
down the mouse button to extend the
tongue further yeah um and that's not
obvious to people yeah and sometimes
they sit there for 30 seconds clicking
and they wonder why it's just like
flicking out and we're trying yeah but
the reason that
I make the player figure that out is
that it and and all the other things is
that it puts them in the mindset of
figuring things out yeah yeah what I
thought like first you have to do it
early I think if you even do like three
or four steps where you're like now do
this now do this and all they're doing
is they get into a mindset of how can I
click through these screens and fastest
yeah and that's not the right frame of
mind if you can get them into this other
frame of mind where they're they're
looking at the whole screen they're
looking for patterns they start to get
like more observant and they start to be
more willing to perform experiments so
and like observe right away like in like
Google and design like the very first
level that is we don't have tutorials
right yeah obviously relieved it there's
a whole tooltip system that's fully
functional and all languages written and
spreadsheet and ready for localization
is just disabled because I think it gets
in and messes up but what would you guys
to talk no problem I think what you guys
are talking about sounds like the way
that I remember playing video games
that's the way like yeah where's this
used to be where to talk about excuse me
the way wise we're totally old yes
you're like turn on your nintendo and be
like how does this [ __ ] weird without
you start the game addresses yeah what
those game designers probably weren't
thinking about it very hard right yeah
yeah here's an interface I know it
really well cuz I made it for a year
yeah and like my Amiga 600 is right that
I don't think right there was any game i
ever played on that had a tutorial
where's like right now in play you know
that's my your guys talking about is
that and then when you look at what's
happening in like big triple-a games
it's like hand holding the entire way
through yeah well i think it's one of
the reasons that dark souls like oh crap
i went there did he was talking about
sex i went there he'll go there and we
won't leave this one short thing which I
think one short thing dan I think I
think that's part of like Dark Souls
just leveling people right being such a
surprise as the game just starts it has
a it sort of has a tutorial but it's
awful it's like really bad the game
starts it's like Fight a skeleton the
skeleton murders you you died that's
like the very first thing that you do
and it's such you can't play it like a
normal Triple A game starting right away
yeah there's like right off that there's
no way to even get to the first area
without losing some of your
preconceptions and I think it perhaps
you to start throwing more of that stuff
away
start playing it by its own terms it
feels like a game from like an alternate
timeline or something and then dark
souls has now prepped millions of
players for games like that yeah it kind
of let paved the way in a lot of letter
respect I think so I mean so that's like
all its that's a problem then right
because like Dark Souls 3 comes out it's
like it's like frog fraction set but it
has you prep them for them yeah really
curious how they're going to handle that
yeah but even taking this back you in a
little bit like this lack of tutorial
and like Indies work on such a small
budget in a small space like we
oftentimes don't have the time or the
ability to hold focus groups or like we
have to design things to teach the
player as we go because otherwise like I
mean we'll lose you like if you turn it
on and we're stuck in like some boring
crap for like it's not like there's
going to be a payoff like if I can just
get through this and you'll be looking
at like this thing that you know took
2,000 people over 10 years and seven
billion dollars to make and we're like
we're on a shoestring budget like three
people for three years and like
especially I'm attracted yeah we have to
lock you in as soon as possible to
understand like no no no it's worth that
I promise I don't actually have to it's
going to be more fun to figure out than
having to handhold you through anyway
it's nice like like what would happen if
Tripoli did start doing this because our
were close to anyone all right disaster
they were all if they were all clever
and letting you complete these gaps and
everything was shiny and covered with
blood all the time like it would be over
so that's your own affair advantage is
that you yeah doing what they're like to
everything yeah that's what you talk to
Mia sake is doing it and nobody else and
just like yeah but I mean little room
for us retaining that must be because
then you're trying to get people out
like a show like this to like play the
game for more than two minutes while
they're like looking over their
shoulders everyone else who's watching
them playing the game it's like what
it's like at a show especially like and
we do this like so when we go to shows
we usually we take like our whole
library so we have like quite a tiny
little ten by ten like four games in it
and like people just mini arcade
happening and when people have to figure
out how to play people behind them start
shouting and collaborating together like
it not your badly you know
positive way people like watching people
play overland at a show is fascinating
we like we like we just stand back are
like let's like the other things when
it's they just play together because
they're like no no this is how you
there's how you do this and they don't
know each other they're not didn't come
to the booth together yeah they're just
like figuring it out together and that's
like the whole point of overland like
that's that's our goals we want people
to play together and create stories
together in this like really cool like
post-apocalyptic space sometimes a group
of three people come up and you can tell
that the wrong one started using the
mouse yes one of the friends just like
no no I'm finally do that get anything
do the mouse doing it wrong I awesome so
what's your guys is main objective them
you come to something like GDC because
there's like people come for like biz
dev people come because each other like
you know talk to marketers they're
trying to a be test their games they're
trying to show it off the press like
what is a few guys yes it's a lot yeah
oh yeah okay yes exactly a big thing
like especially as an indie we work in
our house right together we do have a
great neck where a network of people in
Austin but like our best friends are
scattered throughout the whole world and
those are the people like those are our
co-workers they're working on different
games and doing different things and the
only time that we actually get to see
like the only people in the whole world
who are doing what we're doing is like
while we're in San Francisco for GDC
every year right um and we spend all
week running from place to place like
high-fiving people as would be like
slide through thank you card yeah
basically yeah they're away from people
like oh look at all this like colored
hair and like all this hugging like what
the hell is wrong with bellezza dammit
knees it's like no no don't you
understand we're so alone for so much of
the year and we finally are like in one
place like people will fly here without
a GDC badge just because we're like like
it's sort of like refueling are like I
don't have imagined this year yeah I'm
here to be here to be with people who
understand what you're doing cuz like
you have to be passionate and crazy to
make indie games and watch like it's
hard and expensive and like there's no
guarantee you're gonna make a cent but
sorry that idea it's a basic really bad
idea if you want to make your millions
men do something else no safety not
either
at all which is you know scary well what
about what about yourself Jim when do
you well what's the reason to come here
I power from the fact you live across
the bay I just be in yerba buena park
anyway hi i am i'm literally just here
to hang out with all my cool friends you
know the the the first year I came it
was sort of a business thing and I sort
of had business meetings and and the
second year I think I had one press you
know thing and I would I wouldn't be
talking to press at all if you hadn't
invited me to this oh yeah i mean not
because i don't like them but because it
just wouldn't happen yeah i mean like
come in and talk to us about the game
you've not going to talk to us event
right exactly but but i love having
conversations you know uh and so I've
been just been wandering I've been
walking the earth yeah you know and and
I I know so many of these people by now
it's this is my fourth year I think that
I can just you know sit on the lawn oh
there's somebody I know hi and sometimes
it's nick suttner at Sony and I sort of
have a business meeting yeah you know oh
but most of the time it's just you know
hey it's it's my friend mmm did you feel
like you come away from like an event
like this rejuvenated or cuz like
working as an India to sound like a
rather it's both because I'm a huge
introvert and so I'm utterly socially
exhausted by the end even the first day
frankly and like 11am 1130am starts to
kick in yeah this year I was at that
party last night and I was like walking
I was thinking this is a whole room full
of people who would probably rather not
be here except for everyone else who's
here exactly yeah we'd rather be at home
working on our thing except in this one
case where all the other people who
understand exactly like who I am and
what drives me we're all in the same
room right but ya know it's like its
business its press it's exhausting like
Adam night do GC run every morning so
we're like out warning yeah we're crazy
people like we wake up at like 645 and
we go back to our Airbnb or hotel or
whatever at like sometimes 430am mm-hmm
and it's we sleep the whole way home and
feel like garbage next week but it's
like we have this one week to cram in as
much
like like people and business and
whatever and think about your balance
you start to feel like like especially
as a program you're like well I've got
all these resources in one place I'm
gonna like min max this and make sure
you have a meeting like every 45 minutes
and like say hi to everybody and we get
all the high fives and then but then
also you're trying to not be dead yeah
all right is it's like here yep come
your Bailey's last year we barely broke
out of here without being dead so this
year we like preclose we scaled back the
lack of sleep by doing runs every
morning well no we do that every year
yeah you avoid the hills yeah yeah I'm
gonna run please we encourage people to
stop drinking early or drink very late
so they show up still drunk if they're
gonna run with us no middle ground no
middle ground you got to cut it off at
ten or four ain't any time in between
this trouble fair play ah I guess sort
of like last conversation point to talk
to you guys about is you know there are
a lot of myths about in the development
we were just touching on a couple of
them there and I is you know you guys
were based on in Austin when it was like
cheaper to live there it's getting more
expensive there's more people in the
indie development there there's also
more ways to buy any games the word
India has become this [ __ ] like it
doesn't really mean anything anymore
because it's of scalable but just like
to ask a really annoying journalist the
question is it harder being an indie
developer night and it was five years
ago um that actually it kind of depends
on what parameters you're looking at hmm
um if you it programming way easier it's
way easier to make games yes right yeah
but it's probably harder to make a
living mm-hmm to like get your game
scene is out the same problem yeah yeah
like wanted to sell it it's hard like if
you have something like really special
that you worked on for a long time and
you feel really strongly about it and
maybe it's you know an hour to have kind
of handcrafted something special that
you really loved and so you're like I'm
you know I'm gonna sell some copies of
this or make it like five dollars
because it's about as long as a short
book or a graphic novel or something and
it cost half of that so that seems
reasonable and but also
the the batman game with the tow truck
car and the like five different cities
that's also five dollars yeah and it has
like 200 hours of criminal punching
right so it starts to it starts to feel
like there's like a weird like a lot of
normal business things seem like they
don't really apply or something it's
really strange like should the game
should my game be twenty cents or like
exactly yeah you know which is like how
do you find how do you find the audience
that actually has played enough of the
batman games or has already finished
that one and they are looking for
something and I've new or whatever like
compost sounds around inside our problem
with fire watch where people were like a
$20 like really 20 and then like
Jonathan law with the witness is like 40
like its own like it did nobody there is
no like the perception within you only
games don't sell out Rhino and they're
kind of there forever and as someone
brought up during the show you end up in
a weird position because you're not just
competing them with like in fashion
maybe you're competing with all the new
designs that are out this year and
that's true in games too but you're also
competing with everything that's ever
been made yeah in the last 30 years and
all of its a dollar yeah mm-hmm so like
where do you fit into this it's uh I
don't know David Bowie would know
there's also like a just a perception of
like what an indie person is like if you
make indie games like are you like a
single person in a basement somewhere
living with their parents and like you
know you don't need to make that much
money you didn't find anything to make
it just lazy making a pixel art game
anyway what what the general public
doesn't understand is actually how
expensive it is to make this um I we
talk about sustainability a lot like
that's sort of like our thing you know
we are a married couple like you know
we're in our mid 30s we have two
children we have a what we used to just
sold it but you know modest house our
budget is exactly the same as it was
before we had children right I just cut
all the fat around it because we have it
we have a monthly burn right that we
have to hit which ties into like the
budget of making our really modest
budget for like a three year project
but in order for us to make anything
else is we have to price it to pay for
those three years because we just
emptied out all of our bank accounts
yeah and pay for like the next game that
we're going to make so the idea that you
can spend three years on something and
like you sell it for a dollar like how
many copies of this do I have to push to
make my next game I and like it's all
weird and superfluid because like it's
cheaper it's going to sell more copies
and it sells more copies and more people
play it and they like it then they're
going to tell more people and so like
that user bases growing yep and then
it's like growing exponentially
potentially but if you just nobody plays
it or doesn't really resonate with
people then maybe three years ago you
pick the wrong thing to spend three
years yeah that's hard to fix yeah like
betting on a horse before it's been yeah
so there's so much tension like in like
the price and the quality and the length
because you know like are the two games
that we're working on are actually they
have like Overland has like infinite
replayability and like night in the
woods is just it's the same length as a
lot of like Triple A games like three
people are making a 10 to 14 our game
and we're crazy like that'sthat's like
that size of game with three people is
astounding do you feel like that's what
you need to be doing now though I'm not
so what did I think it's one way sort of
mitigating when we probable it's one way
of mitigating sort of the the pushback
against like you only made a two-hour
thing much like you know well that to
our thing took me like three years
surely innovative a lot of two hour-long
games that have been super successful
yes I've like really caught on so like
it's so hard to make any kind of you
know sweeping anything but we just we we
do look at you have to consider yeah if
you want to pay bills if you want to
have health insurance and all that stuff
kids are ya like like like we definitely
look expensive and a half and we go like
well this game would take three years to
make and it's only going to be an hour
long if people are going to be really
really upset if that our isn't just
every minute of it needs to be
devastating or the ending needs to be
just the most unbelievable ending to
anything that ever happened
and even then it's going to need to be
priced in a slightly different way and
kind of look at all these factors and
try to make a good guess about what's
going on but even then like surely the
process off game development is
iterative in of itself so that means
that like the game that you probably
protected you're going to make like a
three years creative person is like a
lot of time to stick to a plow oh yeah
our post-mortem on overland someday is
gonna be quite a thing because we
started out making a mobile game oh yeah
it is not a mobile game yeah it's just a
thing that happens our little metaphor
is usually like you know you can the
size of a seed and the size of plant
that grows out of it are almost
completely unrelated write those things
just have nothing in common and you just
have to you just client I don't know you
you there's there's some luck involved
in this quote-unquote career well we
wish you the best of luck with all of
your projects thank you so much all
three of you for coming in and talking
to us today Jim I don't even know why
I'm asking this question for people want
to know more about frog fractions to
where should they go why don't you just
watch my video on preserving mystery in
the age of spoiler yeah I pin tweet
right now I'm a Mogwai poet on Twitter
but for [ __ ] great Twitter user name
by the way thank you and yeah it's at
GDC vault right it's just it's not
involved oh really okay I'll order you
all right it's on vimeo oh man yeah that
hot new up-and-coming video parts that's
right yeah I like it awesome what about
you guys overland 10 when can we expect
to see user um so couple things so you
can sign up for the mailing list son and
this is important you want to sign up
for the mailing list for overland at
overland hyphen gamecom and we are going
to be starting a paid private alpha i'll
soon with limited keys that are going to
be released so the only way you're gonna
be able to find out about that is
actually through the newsletter because
we are sort of controlling the scope as
we start rolling out there's gonna be
unlisted sites not googleable okay what
is his literary access team of things no
really access will come later we want
like people who are passionate about
this genre who like wanna sort of get in
and like play our cool thing that we're
building and like be active on the
forums and
like yeah it should be really cool and
it's gonna be like in the next few weeks
cool I people should check it out i've
been super interested in it since I've
for past couple years I I was very happy
to see what was it on IGN a couple days
ago you are now referring to it as XCOM
meets Oregon Trail yeah that's a good
that's it real just as somebody's like
somebody who writes headlines for new
stories and stuff that's that's a real
good one okay good that's our that's our
strong elevator pitch our business
background I like it also thank you so
much for coming in and enjoy the rest of
you GDC thanks thanks to everyone for
listening or watching this wherever
you're consuming this hot piece of
content and if this is on your itunes
RSS feed or whatnot we'll have another
one of these up 2morrow Matt Lee's and
Khalif atoms are going to come in and
talk about the history or in the history
or the current and the future of games
coverage and after watching this on
gamespot of YouTube make sure you
subscribe and we'll have more kool GG
stuff up posthaste thank you so much for
watching and see you next
you